YUFENG GUO: Getting
high quality data
is paramount for good
machine learning outcomes.
But public data
sets aren't always
suitable for custom use cases.
So how can you get
your data labeled
efficiently without spending
days in front of the computer?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "AI
Adventures," where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to take a look
at the cloud AI platform
data labeling
service and see how
it can help you
create labeled data
sets that you can use to
train machine learning models.
While you should always try
to collect data in such a way
that the labels are known
at the time of collection,
that isn't always possible.
Especially in the case of,
say, crowdsourced data,
or unstructured data like
images and video or text,
labeling or data
after collecting it
might be necessary.
The data labeling service lets
you work with human labelers
to create labels for
data that you can then
use to train machine
learning models.
Let's learn a little bit more
about how this system works.
Say you've collected
a representative data
set that you want to
classify or analyze,
and you're ready to try out
creating a data labeling task.
What does it take?
Let's dive in.
The data labeling service
has three core resources
that it uses to define
a labeling task--
data sets, labels
sets, and instructions.
You'll need all three
in order to create
a labeling task for your data.
Now let's look at
each of these in turn.
The data set resource is,
of course, your data set.
It's represented as a CSV
file on Google Cloud Storage.
Each row of the CSV file
points to an individual element
of data.
For instance, if you
a bunch of images,
each row is a GCS
path to an image file.
For text data, each row should
be a path to a text file.
In addition to the
CSV file, you'll
also need to give
the data set a name
and select the data type--
images, video, or text.
Once you've created
your data set,
you'll need to create
your label set.
A label set is the set of labels
you want your human labelers
to use to label your images.
Each label set can
contain up to 100 labels.
You can mix and match data
sets with different label sets
depending on what model
you're trying to train,
or you might even
use the same label
set for several
different data sets.
Try to avoid using labels
whose meanings might overlap,
as this can confuse labelers.
It is also worth
noting that you can
have a label called
neither and both,
which might be useful
especially in, say,
classification scenario.
Once you have a data set
and corresponding label
set created, it's time to
create some instructions
for your labelers.
Here's some tips for
making great instructions.
First up, remember that
labels don't have your domain
knowledge so make sure your
instructions are easy enough
to understand.
Secondly, be sure
to include a list
of all your possible labels with
a description of each label.
And third, in your
instructions, include
examples for every
single label, making
sure to give at least three
positive examples and at least
one negative example covering
different kinds of cases.
Fourth, clarify as many
edge cases as you can.
For example, with say
bounding boxes and images,
be sure to state whether a
partially covered item should
be included and how tightly that
downing box needs to be drawn.
The system requires that
you submit PDF instructions.
So be sure to have some
way to output to PDF.
There is lots of
ways to do this.
One option that
I would recommend
is to just write it up in
Google slides or Google Docs
and save as PDF.
Now that we've created
a data set, label set,
and instructions, we're ready
to bring them all together
to create a labeling task.
The data labeling service
supports many different types
of labeling tasks.
For image data, you can do six
different types of labeling.
There is classification,
bounding boxes,
oriented bounding box, bounding
polygon, polyline tasks,
or segmentation tasks.
For video data, the
data label and service
supports classification, object
detection, object tracking,
and events.
Now, finally, for text
labeling, the service
supports classification,
classification with sentiment,
and finally, entity extraction.
I want to close this video
with some tips for success
and common questions about
the data labeling service.
There is always a concern
about how to ensure
high labeling quality.
One way to ensure the best
labeling quality possible
is to request multiple
human labelers to annotate
each piece of your data.
In cases where there is
disagreement on labeling,
additional opinions
from the other labelers
are gathered until
there is a consensus
or the maximum number of
labelers have been reached.
Let's take a look at an example.
Say we chose to
have three labels.
For image classification
tasks, all three labelers
will classify each image,
and the majority vote
will decide the final answer.
For image bounding box
tasks, the first labeler
will draw the box and the second
labeler then can verify them.
If the second labeler
disagrees and makes edits,
continue on to the third one
to get a majority opinion.
Another potential
area of questions
is around who will
label my data.
All data sets are labeled
by officially onboarded
subprocessors, and
you can find out
more information
and all the details
at the GCP data processing
and security terms.
Anytime you're
transmitting data,
the security and protection
of that data is paramount.
It's worth noting
that all data stored
in Google Cloud is already
encrypted by default
both in transit and at rest.
Human labelers can only view
your data during labeling.
The data labeling service
is also HIPAA compliant,
so for those of you working
with sensitive health care data,
rest assured that it will be
handled in a proper manner.
One final tip, ramp up your data
labeling jobs incrementally.
Start your first labeling job
with a small amount of data
then see whether the
results are what you expect.
You can then revise
your instructions
and then create subsequent
jobs and iterate
until you feel
comfortable sending
larger and larger quantities
of data to be labeled.
This will help you get
high quality results
and make the best
use of your budget,
both in terms of time and money.
I hope this was a useful
overview of the data labeling
service and how you
can get going with it.
And even if you don't need to
use a data labeling service,
these tenants of label
creation and instructions
are important for
creating accurate data
sets for your machine
learning training.
As always, I've linked a
number of useful resources
down in the description below.
Thanks for watching
this episode of Cloud
"AI Adventures," and
if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button
and be sure to subscribe
to get all the latest episodes
right when they come out.
For now, check out the
data labeling service
and create your first
labeling task today.
I look forward to seeing you
next time on "AI Adventures."
[MUSIC PLAYING]